hallo
herzlich willkommen in meine taten welt
heute mache ich ein video über gangart
und das ist eine creme aus schokolade
und sahne
ich verwende die creme meistens und
torten damit zu bestreiten die ich dann
später mit von dort über ziel
die garage ist nämlich eine super creme
um die torten von don tauglich zu machen
das heißt man streicht sie an die
oberfläche der torte und rettet die
torte sozusagen damit und das ist dann
die ideale oberfläche für fondant orten
die brauchen nämlich eine glatte
oberfläche
damit sich da keine luftbläschen bilden
und keine hubl entstehen und ich
verwende zur herstellung von garage
immer ganz normale tafel schokolade also
auch keine kuvertüre die braucht ihr
dann nämlich gar nicht und mit ganz
normale schokolade lässt sie sich super
verarbeiten
die danach stieß ziemlich
variationsreich das heißt ihr müsst euch
nicht auf zartbitter vollmilch oder
weiße schokolade beschränken sondern
können auch andere benutzen wie after
eight oder kinderschokolade yogurette
und alles andere was es da noch so gibt
und das verhältnis da richtet sich eher
nach dem verhältnis von milch schokolade
und sahne
aber das müsst ihr einfach selber
ausprobieren je nachdem ob ihr eben eine
feste oder eine etwas leichtere garage
haben möchtet
bei der herstellung der garagist ist
immer das gleiche prinzip deswegen zeige
ich euch jetzt keine mengenangaben
sondern zeigen euch nur die herstellung
und die genauen mengenangaben findet ihr
wie immer auf meinem blog
und ich sage ich das ist einfach
beispielhaft an der tat bitter gallasch
für die herstellung der ganache gebt ihr
jetzt die sahne in den topf und alles
ist jetzt einmal aufkochen
währenddessen habt ihr die schokolade
kreis
ihr könnt euch etwas arbeit sparen indem
ihr die schokolade nicht in stücke
gehackt sondern sie einfach in kleine
stücke brecht das heißt ihr habt dann
einfach etwas größere stücke die
schmelzen etwas langsamer in der heißen
sonne aber das macht im ganzen
eigentlich nichts und ihr habt euch die
arbeit und die zeit einfach beim hacken
gespart
mittlerweile mache ich das eigentlich
nur noch so weil es für mich eigentlich
schneller geht ihr müsst an die
schokolade einfach in der sahne etwas
länger stehen lassen also stoff 23
minuten einfach vier bis fünf minuten
und danach geht's einfach wie gewohnt
weiter die sahne fängt an zu kochen und
jetzt müsst ihr aufpassen dass sie nicht
überkocht jetzt geschaltete am besten in
heerdt auf und nehmt die sonne vom herd
runter dann gebt ihr die schokolade
vorsichtig in die sammel- und schaut
dass alles mit sahne bedeckt ist und es
lass dir jetzt 23 minuten stehen
danach hört ihr das ganze schön um
ihr könnt ganz gut sehen wie die
schokolade in der warmen sonne schmerzt
und damit die masse dann keine klümpchen
mehr habt müsst ihr das noch einmal
durch pürieren
die garage ist jetzt eigentlich fast
fertig und bevor es jetzt aber weiter
geht zeige ich euch noch wie man die
garage im thermomix einstellen kann dass
ich für diejenigen einfach interessant
die das vielleicht mit dem thermomix
machen wollen weil es da einfach noch
mal weniger arbeit ist ihr braucht
nämlich da nur den mix topf dafür und
spar durch auf den topf und das ganze
geschirr außen rum so im thermomix da
kommt jetzt die fahne in den mix topf
dann kommt der deckel drauf und dann
denke ich reichen drei minuten bei 100
grad
stufe 1 des tana muss jetzt erst mal nur
krochen
ich habe jetzt noch mal eine halbe
minute drauf gegeben es hat nämlich
nicht ganz gereicht
jetzt kommt die schokolade rein und
startest du jetzt ein bissel löffel
verteilen so dass die schokolade
komplett mit der stararchitekt ist also
genau das gleiche prinzip wie auch im
normalen kochtopf und es lässt sie jetzt
auch etwa vier bis fünf minuten stehen
die kochzeit die er vorher ein gibt
richtet sich einfach danach wie viel
sahne ihr in eurem ixtoc haupt und auch
wie kalt die sonne vorher war das müsst
ihr einfach mal ausprobieren und könnte
dann sobald die 100 karten angezeigt
werden einfach den thermomix wieder
ausschalten und auch die zeit die in der
schokolade später drin lassen müsst
damit sie schmilzt richtet sich einfach
danach wie viel schokolade ihr benutzt
von daher müsste es einfach selber
ausprobieren und dann klappt es auch
ganz gut wenn ihr das ganze weiter ab
und kommt der deckel wieder drauf und
dann rührt ihr einfach bei stufe 4
etwa 10 bis 15 sekunden
egal ob idee ghana schied im topf oder
im thermomix hergestellt habt lasst es
jetzt einfach am besten über nacht
auskühlen
die solltet ihr aber nicht im
kühlschrank machen da wird nämlich die
kasse steinhart und lässt sich später
sehr schlecht weiterverarbeiten
ich lasse sie meistens einfach bei
zimmertemperatur stehen oder stellt sie
in einem kühlen raum oder einen kühlen
keller
falls er die garage aber noch am
gleichen tag benutzen wollte stellte sie
einfach für ein paar stunden in den
kühlschrank geschaut aber immer mal
wieder nach ob sie schon fest geworden
ist und rührt auch mal durch damit sie
einfach nicht steinhart wird die creme
lässt sich am besten verarbeiten wie
nächste wieder auf zimmertemperatur
kommen las dann lässt sie sich nämlich
schön durchrühren und vor der
verarbeitung rot ist jetzt einmal noch
mit dem handrührgerät durch und er merkt
ihr einfach auf
falls ihr noch zu kalt ist geht das gar
nicht weil die rück steht gar nicht in
die creme rein gehst wegen lasst ihr sie
lieber bei zimmertemperatur abkühlen
vorher
dann habt ihr danach nicht das problem
dass die creme zu hart ist und sie nicht
weiterverarbeitet werden kann
von jeff morgan
so jedes denn ich habe bisher schon drei
videos veröffentlicht in denen ihr
gesehen habt wie ich gerne streiche und
mich danach die torte eingedeckt habe
und es ist einfacher wenn er die ghana
sport und bestreichen
ganz kurz in die mikrowelle gibt bei
niedriger temperaturen immer mal wieder
um gehört so dass sie die konsistenz von
nuss nougat creme rat als von nutella
zum beispiel da lässt sie sich super
verarbeiten und wenn der kuchen vorher
schön kalt war
dann wird die gala schau auf dem kuchen
erst richtig fest und dann müsst ihr ihn
auch nicht noch nach dem kühlschrank
lassen sondern könnten danach gleich
weiterverarbeiten
ich kann euch jetzt gar nicht genau
sagen wie viel danach ihr herstellen
müsst für eure torte
das hängt nämlich zuerst mal davon ab ob
eure torte der fehler oder eben heiten
hat das heißt ob ihr viel ausgleichen
müssen außerdem kommt auf die größe
darauf an und wie viel creme ihr
benutzten wollt oder benutzen müsse
deswegen macht lieber etwas mehr kann
als zu wenig ich habe mich immer darüber
geärgert wenn ich gerade beim
bestreichen der torte war und dann war
es auf einmal zu wenig ganache da muss
mal wieder den schritt wiederholen die
garage erstellen abkühlen lassen
von daher lieber am anfang etwas mehr
machen falls ihr reste habt könnt ist in
dem ich ganz gut einfrieren und dann
einfach rechtzeitig wieder aus dem
gefrierfach nehmen oder in die
mikrowelle stellen und weiter
verarbeiten das erspart euch im
nachhinein viel mehr arbeit und ihr seid
einfach auf das sicheren seite
eine garage eignet sich aber nicht nur
hervorragend für torten und für motiv
torten
ihr könnt damit auch ganz gut normale
torten dekorieren
dazu macht ihr eine etwas weitere
ganache und gibt sie in einen
spritzbeutel dann könnt ihr schön tupfen
oder spitzer auf die torte spritzen und
sie schön dekorieren ihr könnt auch eine
bizkit rolle damit befüllen
da würde ich aber auch eher etwas
weniger schokolade nehmen und das
verhältnis einfach anpassen und die
garage ist auch die ideale creme für
cake pops
dadurch halten sie sich auch ziemlich
lange es gibt auch die möglichkeit cake
pops mit marmelade herzustellen
die hatten sich auch lange aber ich
finde die variante ehrlich gesagt viel
zu süß
da benutze ich lieber kanalstadt für und
da wären die cake pops schön hart
bleiben schön abstieg leben und
schmecken einfach so kommen
ich hoffe ich konnte euch mit diesem
video weiterhelfen und habe einige
fragen beantworten können
ich werde auf jeden fall noch ein video
machen wie ich eine torte schritt für
schritt mit ganz bestreitet es dauert
allerdings noch bis april mai
denn dann werde ich erst die nächste
motiv torte herstellen
da müsst euch also noch ein bisschen
gedulden ansonsten könnt ihr mir gerne
noch fragen stellen falls fragen offen
sind schaut wieder auf meinem blog
vorbei da habe ich auch schon einen
artikel veröffentlicht über von dann
torten oder sind auch schon die
online-shops mit drin und auch das
rezept für von damit blüten passt und
alles weitere lässt bitte erst nach und
was dann noch offene fragen sind da
wollte ich ihr euch gerne
und das hier ist natürlich nicht meine
küche ich stehe gerade bei meiner mama
in der küche wir sind jetzt noch
umgezogen und ich zeig euch jeden fall
mal noch eine neue küche oder bzw
eine alte küche ich hab sie nämlich
mitgenommen ich habe viele anfragen
bekommen dass ich mal mein werkzeug und
meine küchenmaschine zeige das werde ich
auf jeden fall noch machen und werde ich
auch die shops dazu empfehlen falls es
irgendwelche dazu gibt das kann ich aber
erst machen wenn meine küche komplett
eingerichtet ist und dass wir dann
irgendwann in der nächsten zeit noch
geschehen falls sie dazu noch fragen
habt oder irgendwie spezielle wünsche
dann schreibt mir einfach einen
kommentar und ich werde es auf jeden
fall mit einfließen lassen
bis dann tschüss
bonn germany
red
aber